Over the last couple of weeks,
you might have seen photos
like this flooding your social media feed.
These are the snapshots from Burning Man,
which,
if you don't know, is the notorious mega
cultural event
held in the desert of Nevada,
which they call Black Rock City.
They build stuff.
They burn stuff.
And over the timespan of nine days,
these group of people live together
and they function together
around the ten core principles of radical
inclusion, gifting,
commodification, radical self-reliance,
radical self-expression,
communal effort, civic responsibility,
leaving no trace participation
and immediacy.
A portion of this video
is sponsored by Soundcore.
More on them later in this video.
It started in 1986 with just 20 people.
But it's been growing by the thousands
every single year.
And this year it held about 80,000 people.
But throughout Burning Man's history,
there's been multiple accidents,
deaths, arrests, as well as some
really horrific stories of sexual assault.
And in spite of their principle
of radical inclusion,
the desert environment
doesn't really seem exactly
like the most hospitable place
for people with mobility issues.
Some of the installation
seemed to not meet any kind of safety
regulation, and in fact,
throughout its history there's
been concern run ins with law enforcement
and the Bureau of Land Management.
And with this type of massive growth
every year.
They've been constantly dealing
with functional concerns,
traffic safety concerns, problems
with scale and accessibility.
So how has this event continued on
for so long and why is it growing so fast
and how did it go from this to this?
What's up, guys?
My name is Danny and I am an architect
in beautiful Vancouver, B.C.
And when I started looking
at the history of Burning Man,
I was actually really shocked.
And I think it's a really fascinating case
study from a design and urban
planning point of view.
This place has no water, no vegetation,
and the temperatures,
they get up to 100 degrees Fahrenheit
and they drop to freezing at night.
And they have windstorms
that kind of cover everything in dust.
And despite all of that, every summer,
these group of people assemble
a small city,
and after nine days, they disassemble it
and they leave zero trace
of any human presence.
I think Burning
Man is a really interesting example of how
constrains, whether it's legal
or functional or site specific,
how these constraints have shaped a city
into something that's so successful.
In fact,
the very first plan of Burning Man
was developed in 1992 for a population
of just 600, just to satisfy
the permitting requirements in 1996
with a population of 8000.
The added avenues for the very first time
and a second circle.
And in order
to preserve the view of the burning Man,
they created a zone called No Man's Land,
lined on either sides with theme camps
and which were and to this day
are kind of the heart of Burning Man.
It can be anything from services,
entertainment or other interactive
experiences organized by the people,
for the people as gifts to the community.
Still, with more growth,
they were constantly
having issues with traffic, chaos, sprawl.
And every year they were losing
the intimacy
of the original camping circle,
which led to accidents
and a sense of isolation and conflict
between people.
Shut up.
Here, try this.
What is this?
It's sound course. Sleep at home.
It's got enhanced noise blocking system,
and it's got a massive sound library
to help you improve your sleep.
It's also got a four point noise
masking system and it blocks out
35 decibels of noise, which is 15 decibels
more than your standard earbuds.
But I'm a side sleeper.
No problem.
It's lightweight,
so it stays in your ears very snugly.
Oh. Oh.
Check the link in the description
for a limited time offer.
Whoa.
In 1997, Burning Man took place
in a different location
near Kuala Pae Valley.
This is when they recruited Rod
Garratt, who's a landscape architect
by training, and he put together
the plans and documents
to meet the regulations of the county.
The permitting requirements,
if for some to include roads and street
names and urban amenities
and due to the constraints of the site.
Also, in order to condense everything
within the property line in naturally
developed this arc that's spread out
laterally from the center.
The year after, in 1998,
when they returned to their home
in Nevada, they kept a lot of the aspect
from their experiment.
In 1997, they decided to form the city
into a concentric circle
around a geographic center
where you could see the men.
Just conceptually.
I really love this idea of a moving city.
Like it's a city that morphed itself
to meet
the constraints of this new site
and learn from its conditions.
And then when it came back home,
have become a better version of itself.
By the early 2000, Burning Man had grown
to 25,000 people
officially the size of the town.
And I think here
you can see one of the most understated
and fascinating things
about the evolution of Black Rock City.
So this was the point where a lot of the
problems really started to get amplified.
There were staff disruptions
and splinter groups and safety concerns,
and the planners of Black Rock City
identified that a lot of these problems
can be traced back to alienation
leading to the loss of human connection.
So they decided to ban vehicles
except for the approved art vehicles.
They tried to make the settlement
a little bit more walkable.
And the proposal to the plan
was to instead of having this thick
band of theme camps in the prime, inside
ring of the city,
that these camps would be distributed
throughout the plan.
This meant that they had to break down
these monolithic sections, and when they
did find some success with the strategy,
they started interjecting more
and more of these theme camps
into the rest of the site year after year.
But of course, it's
when you start getting these mixed use
scenarios where you start
to have more obvious issues.
For example, having like a dance party
themed camp next to like a quiet
relaxation zone,
that could be problematic.
And that's actually why so many cities
are zoned with very distinct uses.
This requires a lot more granular planning
from everyone involved.
So Roger Garrett,
he started implementing zoning
to separate the potentially clashing uses.
And months before the event,
people have to submit the plans
for their camps for approval.
There is fairly strict guidelines,
it seems like, for
the design of these camps
with like dimensions
and potentially conflicting uses
as well as pretty much everything else.
But can this really solve
the problem of safety and accessibility?
Throughout Burning Man's history,
there's been numerous
deaths and near fatal accidents.
There's open fires.
There's art vehicles,
and the art installations are claimable.
And of course, you can't compare
Burning Man to a real city.
You know, people only come here
for nine days, and after that
they go back to the safety
and comforts of their own homes.
And none of these are like
real permanent structures.
But just to put things in perspective,
the safety regulations of the building
code is so, so, so, so strict
that, for example,
something that I just came across
the other day with my project is let's say
we have an existing building, right?
And a fire exit this way and a fire exit
this way and a path this way.
And this is like a grassy area.
And so we decided to put windows
right here to give a little bit
more daylight into this admin space.
But the city wanted us to put
water curtains,
which are kind of like sprinklers
above these windows.
And they wanted a new path here
because in case there's a fire,
we have to assume that people
are going to come out of the building
and they're going to be like, Oh, my God,
where do I go?
I must follow this path.
But there is only one path,
and we have to assume
that they're either going to go this way
or this way.
And if they go this way,
there's like a massive raging fire
that's going to shoot out this window
and people are going to get hurt.
But in reality and in common sense,
when people leave a burning building,
they're going to be walking out
in all directions
and they're not going to care whether it's
a paved path or if it's a grassy area.
So this is like one of the few examples.
But anyways,
what I'm trying to say is the building
code forces us
to put these safety precautions in place
that sometimes go a little bit
beyond common sense.
And they really force us to design
for the most extreme scenarios.
And every time they print a new building
code, it's built
upon the accidents or like the lawsuits
from the years before.
But the point of all of this
is to provide a safe and equitable place
for everyone, you know, no matter what
your physical or mental capacities are.
Because if you don't put in rules
like this, you'll get designs like this.
So doesn't this and this kind of go
against one of their core principles
of radical inclusion?
The weird thing is, even in
probably one of the most
inhospitable conditions,
there's actually quite a large community
of people with disabilities at Burning Man
that actually come back year after year.
They have what's called a mobility camp
since 2012, whose camp
motto is radical inclusion
through radical accessibility.
And they have things like wheelchair
accessible camping power
for medical equipment.
They are volunteers and they take out
a tractor and like a 20 foot accessible
trailer rig out onto the desert
three or four times a day,
so that people who can't bike or walk,
they can still experience the art
by which they do
make it very clear on the Burning
Man website the reality of the conditions
at the event.
And they really stress
that, you know, even though
there's a big support network, everyone,
you know, no matter what
your physical capabilities
is expected to live by the principles
of participation
and radical self-reliance.
And I think, weirdly enough, that's
one of the reasons
why they feel empowered and accepted.
They're not just seen as helpless or seem
just for their disabilities.
They're just another burner
or that's what they call themselves
that use the art to express themselves.
That's my
of Who's an advocate for accessibility
based in Toronto.
And I think she really nailed it
on the head.
I mean, first, it needs to be functional
and it needs to be accessible,
but that's kind of the bare minimum.
Like once you figure that out,
how can we create environments
that give everyone
the same quality of experience
and the same quality of life
and when you start
looking at the environment
from that lens, you're going to start
to see a lot of problems
in a lot of standard design practice
and in a lot of like award winning spaces
by a lot of award winning architects.
But also, if you're smart, I think
you'll also start
to see more opportunities in this.
If you think architecture is stagnant.
This is one of the ways
we're going to get new types of spaces.
And I think it's something that all of us
can do kind of on a daily basis
if you're going somewhere.
Just try to think
if I was on a wheelchair,
like how would I get here
if I was visually impaired?
How would I do that?
And by understanding and recognizing that,
I think we can develop
more empathy and we can have better
and stronger communities.
So where am I going with all of this?
As an architect, I do want to attribute
the success of Burning Man to the design.
But I am it's not I think it's actually
the social strategy behind their design
and the urban plan.
This is a quote from Larry Harvey, who's
one of the co-founders of Burning Man.
He said, We've shown that
you can actually deal with the complexity
of urban problems
by using specifically cultural means.
The citizens participate
in creating the city.
In fact, half of our control is just based
on watching their behavior
and meeting their needs.
And that's the whole history
of the development of the city.
So what is participation on one level?
Participation
means that people should enter up
with others and engage in the activities
and not be voyeuristic.
On a deeper level, participation
means that aside
from the limited government
that handles like the basic infrastructure
and like emergency services,
the citizens they co-create
and they maintain the city
and essentially it's civic engagement.
I think there's something kind of magical
that comes from the process
of building something together.
When I interviewed Scott Kemp
and some other architects
who work with indigenous communities,
a lot of them,
they don't see architecture
or the building as their end goal.
Their goal is to use the process
of building
as a way to heal the communities
and to bring them together.
And in fact, Scott
went as far as to say that he's not really
the one who designs the buildings,
like the community designed them,
and he's just the hand
that draws what they design.
Even if you're contributing
at a really small level,
like gifting someone a cookie
or saying hi to your neighbors,
you are participating
in building the social fabric of the city.
And if you don't like something,
you can talk to someone.
In normal cities,
there's just like so many steps
you have to get through bureaucracies
and there's political barriers.
And eventually
people feel pretty powerless in the end.
But in essence, I think it's
the principle of participation
that's allowed Burning Men
to transform from this to this.
And I think this is how they've been able
to continue growing through
so many years of conflict
with the authorities.
I do wonder if going to Burning Man
actually affects people's attitudes
when they leave the event
and come back to their normal lives.
But I mean, I would kind of assume
that if you've had
a really positive experience somewhere,
it kind of changes a little part of you.
I don't know.
I've never been to Burning Man,
but I would kind of like to go.
It sounds really cool.
Let me know what you think.
If you like this video,
remember to like and subscribe.
And if you like this video,
you might also like my other video
where I discuss a very different type
of settlement in the desert.
I'll leave the link right here.
And with that,
I'll see you in the next one.